hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
this is the first video I've made since
we hit 1 million subscribers still blows
my mind please accept my gratitude thank
you so much it's a cliche but it's
absolutely true I wouldn't be here
without you I'm still working on that
face reveal video so let's crack on and
get through this one we are heading into
December 2019 the last chance for game
publishers to take advantage of the
Christmas rush most of the huge
blockbuster games have already released
but there are still one or two which
deserve your attention oh and this month
I managed to find another free-to-play
game which drops in the first week of
December the game of the month for me is
ancestors the humankind Odyssey which
finally makes its way over to consoles
on December the 6th it's from one of
those masterminds behind the success of
Assassin's Creed but ancestors is a game
like no other this is survival
the evil ocean of survival right away
the greatest and worst thing about the
game are the tutorials there isn't any
zero hand-holding all mechanics are
learned in game through experimentation
and good old trial and error and for
this reason the reviews have been
scattered but if you get into the
mindset of early man that's how they
felt clueless
do you know how to make fire well you'll
need to figure it out quickly I suppose
though you could google everything but
what's the fun in that
over time your user skill tree to unlock
new abilities and to attempt to make it
the millions of years to get to the
human stage of evolution fighting off
alligators and other predators swinging
from tree to tree to further the species
definitely not a game for everyone but
surviving as an ape seems interesting at
the very least
[Music]
next up is the episodic adventure we
first spoke about back in September 2018
life is strange - on December the 3rd
the fifth and final chapter of the story
will be told additionally if you're like
me episodic games don't fit your gaming
style so therefore on December the 3rd
you can grab up the collector's edition
which includes all episodes allowing us
to binge play the full story without
months of waiting in between episodes
fYI life is strange - is set three years
after the original game call it a
graphic adventure call it an interactive
movie or maybe a storybook with slightly
branching paths this is completely about
narrative focusing around brothers Shaun
and Daniel after the street they live on
explodes I'm trying my best not to spoil
anything in the first episode basically
you'll be running from the police and
you have superpowers I've already said
too much
[Music]
ok so let's look at the free-to-play
game for December 2019 this is cuisine
Royale on December 3rd it finally makes
it over to ps4 and although there are
many versions which cost money always
remember this is a free-to-play game so
ignore paid content until you know if
it's the game for you at its core this
is another Battle Royale
very close to pub G the game itself
though began life as a joke between
friends
but somehow it was completed and here we
are
the game has micro mechanics like
leaning vaulting and going fully prone
so that's why I don't really compare it
to fortnight probably h1z1 would be the
best comparison so why is it called
cuisine Royale well the armor is all
pots and pans found in kitchens and the
loot system is made up of food and other
dishes this is the trollee astata Royale
game you will ever play I am really
hungry talking about this game a random
question what's the greatest food you've
ever eaten up votes your favorites in
the comments
I need suggestions for my dinner
at the polar opposite of cuisine Royale
is a rise a simple story available on
December the 3rd on ps4 PC and Xbox one
from watching the trailers arise feels
much like journey from back in 2012 so
expect an emotional story with an
exemplary soundtrack the official blurb
says this journey through the
bittersweet lives of two people where
memories come alive and time bends to
your will lose yourself in moments of
happiness and overcome every hardship as
you relive your life story a story of
joy and sorrow hmm maybe we will need
the tissues after all December the 3rd
if you're interested December has so
many games releasing DLC so I've just
picked one for this time around horror
fans you should know that dead by
daylight releases The Nightmare Edition
on December the 6th which includes
almost everything released by the game
since its inception DLC four days so now
is a good time to convince your friends
to join you or upgrade the version of
dead by daylight they already home so as
it's so difficult to find new games this
month I think we better just stop there
I'll be trying out ancestors over
Christmas and I honestly can't wait to
jump into cuisine Royale are we trying
to convince my discard to do the same it
could be a really good meet up anything
float your boat this month I'm adding
from PlayStation grenade and I'm gonna
go get back to my face reveal video haha
I don't want to do it I'll see you soon
[Music]